Welcome back.
So where I left off
we said that I was
going to throw a ball.
And I threw it at an angle of
45 degrees to the ground.
Let me draw the ground
in green as
hopefully the ground is.
That looks more like green
water, but I think you get
what I'm saying.
So I throw a ball at a 45 degree
angle and I throw it
at-- what did I say?
I think it was 10 meters
per second.
I want to figure out how far
this ball will go or how high
does-- not how high.
Well, I could figure
that out as well.
Or how long does the ball
stay in the air.
And what we said is we can
break this vector.
This vector has magnitude 10
in the 45 degree direction.
We can break into its vertical
and horizontal components.
So it's horizontal components,
this horizontal component
would be this vector.
And its vertical component
Whoops.
The other way around.
Vertical and horizontal are
always the two things that I
found most confusing.
Its vertical component would
be this vector and its
horizontal component would
be this vector.
Sorry for confusing it.
And so we could treat it just
like the sides of a right
triangle because as we know, the
vertical is perpendicular
to the horizontal.
And what I find very fascinating
by that is we're
dealing with the velocities and
we can still treat them
like they're the sides
of a right triangle.
And that's why vectors in
general are so useful.
And as we do more problems,
hopefully you
get more of an intuition.
And we said from the previous
problem that-- well, not the
previous problem, the previous
presentation-- the length of
this side, if you just use your
basic trigonometry would
be-- the vertical component
of my velocity, so
that's v sub v.
So v sub vertical, which is an
unconventional way to write
it-- would be 10 sine
of 45 degrees.
And that equals what?
What's sine of 45 degrees?
That's square root
of 2 over 2.
So it's 10 times square root
of 2 over 2, which equals 5
square root of 2.
And the horizontal component
of my velocity is
10 cosine 45 degrees.
To figure out this and this
we just used soh cah toa.
We just said that the vertical
velocity over the hypotenuse
is equal to sine
of 45 degrees.
And then we just rearranged
it to get this.
And we said that the horizontal
velocity over the
hypotenuse is equal to the
cosine of 45 degrees and then
we solved it to get this.
We solved for the horizontal
velocity.
And this also equals
5 square root of 2.
So what can we do now?
This is what I find to be the
really interesting part.
If we wanted to figure
out how long does the
ball stay in the air?
The only thing that's keeping
the ball from staying in the
air forever is gravity.
Gravity is what's bringing the
ball back down to the ground.
And gravity only works in
the vertical direction.
Gravity only works-- I don't
like this color.
Gravity only works in the
vertical direction, always
pulling directionally down at 10
meters per second squared.
So what we can do is we can
break this problem up into two
problems.
We can say well this ball is
going to stay up in the air
just as long as a ball that was
thrown straight up with
the same vertical velocity.
This ball is going to stay up in
the air for the same amount
of time as something thrown
straight up at 5 square root
of 2 meters per second.
And I want you to think
about that.
Because that's actually-- at
least, when I first learned
it, it wasn't intuitive.
And the more you think
about it, it
kind of becomes intuitive.
And then you might want
to experiment with it.
A ball that's thrown at an
angle will stay up-- well
let's say a ball that's thrown
at an angle that gets as high
as like-- let's say it gets
as high as 500 meters.
Let's say I throw a ball
and this is the
motion of the ball.
So let's say this is the
path of the ball.
The ball looks like this.
And let's say the highest point
that the ball traveled,
let's say this is 500 meters.
That would be a very--
probably more like a
cannonball or something.
I can't throw a ball
500 meters high.
So this is the ball that's
actually thrown at an angle.
That travels some distance
along the ground.
What I'm saying is that this
ball is going to stay in the
ground-- is going to stay in the
air the exact same amount
of time as a ball
that does this.
And this is 500 meters.
That's interesting.
The difference between these two
balls-- and I'm probably,
I should probably use
different colors.
The difference between this
ball, which is thrown at a
steeper angle, then this ball,
which is thrown at kind of a--
it looks almost like a 45 degree
angle, is that this
ball's horizontal velocity,
its velocity in this
direction was lower.
This ball had a much better
horizontal velocity.
But the time that they stay in
the air-- and once again,
we're assuming nothing about
air resistance or anything.
The time they stay in the
air is exactly the same.
That's really interesting.
Another way to think about it
is, if I'm on a cliff and I
just drop a ball and it just
goes straight down on a 500
meter cliff, that ball is going
to take the same amount
of time to hit the ground.
It's going to take the same
amount of time to hit the
ground as if another ball that
was moving-- let's say it was
moving, it only had
horizontal motion.
So the second ball
goes like this.
So it moves along
the horizontal
axis the whole times.
So it's moving to the
right the whole
time while it's falling.
But both of these balls--
let me draw the
second ball in magenta.
This second magenta ball is
going to take the same amount
of time to hit the ground.
And that's because its vertical
velocity at any given
time, its velocity in the
downward direction is going to
be the exact same.
And that's because gravity
is only pulling in
the downward direction.
I want you think about that a
lot because that's kind of a
core intuition of vectors and
physics, is that you can break
out the velocity into horizontal
and vertical
components.
And that once you do, kind of
the things that are affecting
it in the vertical component
are identical regardless of
what's happening in
the horizontal.
So that might have
been helpful.
It might have confused
you further.
But let's just continue
on with the problem.
So let me put this a little
bit of the side.
I took too much space.
So my vertical velocity is going
to be 5 square root of 2
meters per second up.
And we're going to stay with the
convention positive is up
and negative is down, just like
in the coordinate axis.
So how long is it going
to stay in the air?
If I threw a ball straight up
at 5 square root of 2 meters
per second, how long is it
going to stay in the air?
Well, the way I think about it,
the easiest way to think
about it is the same amount of
time it takes to go up is the
same amount of time it's going
to take it to go down.
We learned that in a couple
of videos before.
So how long is it going
to take it to go up?
Well to go up, it's going to
start at this speed, 5
square root of 2.
And then at the top, when it's
at the top, it's going to be
going-- it's going
to have 0 speed.
So it's going to decelerate from
5 square root of 2 to 0
in some amount of time.
And here we could just use a
very simple equation: change
in velocity.
Change is velocity is equal to
acceleration times time.
Well what's the change
in velocity?
It's the final velocity, which
is 0, minus my initial
velocity, minus 5 square root
of 2 is equal to the
acceleration.
That's 10 meters per
second squared.
And forgive me for not putting
the units in right now because
I'm running out of space.
Times time.
So if we solve for t, we get--
the negatives cancel out.
The 0 doesn't matter.
So we get t is equal to 10 over
5 square root of 2, which
equals 2 over the square
root of 2 seconds.
t equals 2 over the square
And of course, if we wanted to
rationalize this, we could
multiply the top and
the bottom by the
square root of 2.
Well actually, you don't
have to do that.
What's 2 divided by the
square root of 2?
Well that's just equal to the
square root of 2, right?
Because the square root of 2
times the square root of 2 is
of course, 2.
So it takes a square
root of 2 seconds.
But is that the total time that
the ball's in the air?
No, that's the amount of time it
takes for the ball to go to
its highest point.
It takes square root
of 2 seconds to go
to its highest point.
But then it's going to take the
exact amount of time to
come back down.
So the total time in the air
is going to be-- and I know
I'm doing this very messy.
The total time in the air
is 2 square root of 2.
Just two times this.
Because it takes the same amount
of time to go up as it
does to come down.
And it might be confusing, but
all I did is I figured out the
vertical component of the
velocity using some basic
trigonometry.
And I said well, it's going to
decelerate with gravity and
over that time, when it's going
up, however long it
takes is going to be going from
that initial-- that 5
square root of 2 meters
per second to 0.
So how long does it take to
decelerate from 5 square root
of 2 to 0 given that I'm
decelerating with gravity?
Given that I'm decelerating at
10 meters per second squared.
And it takes us 2 square
root of 2 seconds.
I will continue this
in the next video.